tell us what happened with the staff
Council so I've just left the staff
council meeting where the majority of
trade unions voted to as you said voted
to accept the agreement in their
individual consultations unions met
together and then met with employers and
we confirmed that position was a
majority to accept the payoffer and a
majority that want to go ahead and
Implement and on that basis the
Secretary of State attended the meeting
and confirmed that he will be moving to
implement the pay offer so we're hoping
this means that health workers can
expect the payments in their pay packets
in June we've got to confirm the fine
detail on that I think unison's priority
is to make sure that we can go forward
and bring a resolution a similar
resolution to the dispute that's ongoing
in Northern Ireland and if you recall
health workers working in Northern
Ireland have only just had the 1400
pounds that health workers in England
received back in September 22 because of
the the length of time it's taken given
their political situation so we want a
situation to come forward where we can
have a resolution to the dispute in
Northern Ireland we also want to talk
about what happens to all of the the
staff who work for private contractors
in the NHS so these are people who
deliver vital NHS services but who are
often paid by Third parties so those are
going to be the priorities as well as
making sure we're able to take forward
those non-pay elements of the of the
payoffer and Prime amongst those was a
review of the pay setting process itself
had we been in that position this time
last year we may not have had to have
any dispute in the in the Health Service
this year but very important we learn
lessons this is quite a significant
moment does this effectively mean that
the dispute between health workers and
the government is now now over so it
certainly means that the majority of
unions have resolved their disputes
certainly my own Union Unison our
dispute is now is now resolved in
England it's important to note it was a
majority decision not a unanimous
decision and there were unions who uh
you know you'll have to talk to them
about their position so it was a
majority position our priority as Unison
is to make sure that we're able to bring
a similar end to the dispute that we
have in Northern Ireland on behalf of
health workers there and that we're able
to confirm very quickly that health
workers will get the additional lump sum
which was worth between sixteen hundred
and four thousand pounds for 22.23 that
people will get confirmation that that
will be in the June pay packets your
press release did not give a breakdown
are you able to share the numbers with
us you said a majority yeah no that's
this staff council issue we're active
group and it was a majority position
that was that was that was reached I
mean you've been reporting very actively
on the position of individual unions but
I think what's what's really important
is that we can go forward with some
Unity hoping to take forward both the
not only just the the implementation of
the uh the outcome to the payoffer but
the discussions about those non-uh those
non-pay items so there were some really
big ticket uh bits of of work there like
making sure that we're able to have
people sign up for apprentices from
within the service and if they want to
go on an apprenticeship and that's
agreed as part of development that those
people can do that without suffering a
detriment in pay also lots of lots of
work to do about how we better support
people not just when they're moving into
their first job in the Health Service
but support people to develop in their
goals and progress through pain now I
know you don't want to speak on behalf
of other unions but you are the the
chair of the NHS staff council meeting
today members that were on that meeting
RCN unites they've rejected the
government's often what did they tell
you today that um how did they feel
about accepting the government's office
well you'll understand that today was
about reporting positions not talking
about our feelings
um so you know the the unions reported
back their positions and you know we we
have a tried and tested
um you know means of resolving
differences between unions I think you
you know if you've covered the health
brief for a while you'll know that it's
not very often we end up with all of the
agenda for change trade unions in
exactly the same position in fact I
struggle to recall a you know a key
position where we've had every single
Union in the same position so what we
will try and do is work together as best
we can over the over the coming months
there's obviously some tough decisions
for unions that you know that were in a
reject position we have to recognize
that but also you know acknowledge the
fact that we've got a clear majority
position and that members of unions that
accepted have a very strong mandate to
want the government to implement and
make sure this gets into pay packets as
soon as possible it was fractious as a
trade Union nest yourself you wouldn't
have wanted to see that division among
the unions oh it would be lovely if
everybody agreed with each other all of
the time but you know as I just said 14
trade unions representing
um you know workers who are covered by
the Same by the same pay agreement over
uh you know over a million workers
represented there so it's it it is
always a very complex landscape that's
why um you know that's why several of us
on the staff side have great hair it's
not you know it isn't easy getting uh
you know getting these these joint
positions but we have a very strong
joint position today a majority position
to accept and Implement and let's move
forward hoping that we do not end up in
this situation again